this tram is funded built and at least
for now operated by Chinese entities but
we're nowhere near China this is the
Ethiopian capital Addis Ababa and the
tram is the first light rail project of
its kind in Africa Chinese investment in
infrastructure forms the backbone of
Ethiopia's ambitious development plan as
well as creating jobs it also serves as
a way to transfer knowledge the
topiaries corporation will enforce the
contractors in the consultants to hire
local subcontractors as well as
employees through that process also
there has been a long much amount of
technology transfer when it comes to
infrastructure development in Africa
China has the edge it's able to offer
attractive loans and a vast labor force
as Ethiopia's biggest trading partner
China stands to benefit from projects
like these but according to the Chinese
ambassador to Ethiopia others do too
China sometimes feel lonely because we
are almost one of the biggest and the
only country that has it has invested
heavily in the development in the
development of infrastructure in this
country because we believe finally the
development infrastructure has not only
served the local people the host country
it has also served the investors from
other countries other projects built by
Chinese contractors include the African
Union's headquarters many of addis ababa
roads an industrial zone and a new
railway to Djibouti the economic payoff
will take time but chinese officials say
these infrastructure projects are proof
of the country's unique approach towards
Africa the World Bank however has warned
that Ethiopia may be borrowing too much
to finance these projects for most
ordinary Ethiopians though the
development in the capital are welcome
despite that some wonder if they're
getting enough bang for their buck
as in fuselage no let me so be set up
it's good they're building the tram to
reduce the traffic jams in the city
regard to quality I think the Chinese
did an okay job but still it might have
been better to give it to a Western
company the quality may not be top-notch
but for a country like Ethiopia having a
tram at all is a great source of pride